passage à l'euro réussi dans les
supermarchés français pour ce premier
vrai jour de shopping en euro marqué
traditionnellement par une augmentation
de 25 % des achats selon la Commission
européenne la moitié des paiements en
liquide se sont fait en euros dans les
pays concernés et les caissières ont
fait face avec sérénité Nathalie Moisan
et Patrick
daschmeker l'affluence d'un samedi
après-midi au supermarché Virginie est
l'une des 40 caissières à prendre son
poste pour elle aussi c'est une journée
testess pêcher faut bien rendre la
monnaie faut bien faire le décompte et
sinon c'est un PEI
comme un petit peu par rapport au rendu
monnaie je vous remercie monsieur au
revoir très vite une surprise l'euro
gagne du terrain ici la file s'allonge
pour la monnaie unique là les caisses
réservées au franc sont vides à la hâte
on bascule sans difficulté majeure du
franc en euros dans l'après-midi seul 10
caisses sur 40 sont encore consacré à
l'ancienne monnaie et rares sont les
irréductibles qui continuent de décrier
l'euro
on a eu le Fran fort on a le Fran lourd
on a l'Euro mais on est toujours aussi
pauvre alors maintenant c'est
R pour Virginie l'euro s vite la routine
sauf quand la petite monnaie fait défaut
petit minutes je va pas avoirz de
mon les caissr redoutai les faux euros
et deè surprise du jour ce sont les faux
francs qui réapparaiss ici ou là on
obser depuis depuis mercredi
derniernormément deux billets de 500
francs qui ressortent donc on les fait
absolument tous contrôler par que là il
ressort des armoires donc en attendant
les paiements par carte chè
progresse comme si les Français étai
déjà en passe de vier leur B de laine à
cette vitesse le Fran pourrait
disparaître définitivement bien avant le
février